back in the glue thing too by the way
nice you know I I don't know people know
this but I you know arm I'm really into
Elmer's glue mm-hmm and I put it on my
fingers I put it on my feet and I've
done it since I was a baby and there's
years where I I have to things like that
sunflower seeds I just go through like
you know periods where I do it and then
I don't do it
I want a glue run right now nice just on
my thumbs oh where does it help with
nothing oh it doesn't do anything I just
I love doing it you ever do your feet I
do all the time we actually have
hundreds of his glue thumb hands in the
closet yeah and at some point we have to
give give them out and give those away
as tiger man you know why I've never
given them away because people have
asked for it you know why why oh yeah
there's a no there's a murder you frame
that I'm framed be done yeah my
thumbprint we just get people so many
ideas the frame you know I'm not good at
I know I know for a fact even if I
didn't come into crime and cops had me
you know first of all lie-detector test
I'll fail every single one of them
because of your anxiety yeah I feel like
even like if they ask me the question
like did you rate miss Donahue you did
anything right and even if I did even if
I say no once I say no idea in my mind
I'll be like they're gonna know I didn't
do it but they're gonna you know mean so
you're gonna think that I did and then
it's gonna affect the Machine just like
you know the rattle yeah I would be the
worst candidate for it as well look at
my hands right now yeah they're already
sweating just at the thought of
formulating a sentence yeah just by
breathing I'm already so we have
problems hey you and I would be fun we
talked it we'd be in prison or like you
know when like Brendan Dassey and making
a murderer you know I mean they were
like feeding him lines yeah I would be
the same way no you wouldn't exhaust
everything nobody little did in my head
I'm like I gotta watch you know you mean
let's say there's a fight UFC fight yeah
and they had me in her office and I'd be
like so just say that you did it I go
yeah but okay but or I did it because I
got to go so what to fight oh you got to
go what to Conor McGregor a ps2 yeah
yeah which is not happy so he'd take
heed take the punishment
so he didn't watch that or rematch in
time yeah I'm so glad I've never been
framed for anything you know I don't
really don't anything bad like that you
guys both went to prison at all I've
been locked up but I'm not going to
specify why I didn't know that you were
locked up in a prison no not in a prison
Oh Oh in a mental institution that's not
what you meant you say it like the
mental institution no you were like I'm
in like jail no she was like a goth
chick and she was a cutter or whatever
no we've all gone through that yeah but
not in a prison you've been you're never
been do it no better than locked up
three times I'm a repeat offense yeah
I've been locked up also but I don't
view that as being locked up but no they
have they take away all your rights they
[ __ ] basically tranquilize you you're
in there for a month they you can you
don't have access to you you have to
give up all your contraband right so
it's like you don't even have access to
gummy worms you don't have access to
that's the first thing you had essica
bringing me like those little Asian
jellies so yeah she brought me those
asian jelly brought you in as and jelly
didn't allow me to have it and I flipped
the [ __ ] out because I was just like I
wasn't allowed and he just bounced of
happiness in there because but you know
you worried you relinquish that right
when you go try and kill yourself
you know of course so the government now
you know deems you you know incapable of
[ __ ] jelly very good I know I was so
upset
yeah like when if that journal that I
have that little blue journal that I
have if I read some of those excerpts
and they make me cringe why came because
I you know I want to kill myself life is
worthless meaningless you know so emo
yeah super emo
nice do the coffee shops hey stably code
this place in Pacific Beach called
Zanzibar feel like 3:00 in the morning
yeah and play chess and write poetry
really yeah and then I had like
discussions with like older like
bohemian people about music it was so
[ __ ] disgusting
doesn't seem like you Adam yeah because
I had no yeah and you know when Europe
when you don't know what you want to do
with your life
and yet you're lazy like I'm like I
don't want a day job I've never wanted
to work not because I'm lazy I mean when
I do work I'm a hard worker but I hate
it everyone hates to work yeah but like
I just during my off time I would just
spend time like you cuz I knew I wanted
to do something creative you don't know
what it is yet because you're 20 21
years old so I would go to local punk
shows but then I was also state late and
write poetry and stuff I was very very
similar but they were there was always
older men that I came across who really
preyed on young emo girls like me they
would say things like I remember working
at a 24-hour Fitness when I was in high
school and I did sales and the GM he
drilled is like fancy Porsche duo he'd
always be like hey come in here and just
like talk to me and read me your poems
you know and I thought thought to be
such an honors I would sit there and I
would read him all my poetry and then
he'd be like here here's 200 bucks just
for your weekend
and you know when I was 16 years old and
I thought to myself wow you really likes
my poetry because I never I never like
hooked up with it he didn't like the
poet
[Music]